okay ready yep we visited Brian
Baumgartner and Angela Kinsey on set and
they showed us their best beer pong
techniques they'll cover how to score
points how to prevent your opponent from
scoring and how to be the life of the
party this is a game called beer pong
right yeah I'm all excited I've never
played before
first up Angela and Brian show us how to
get the perfect arc for the basic shot
first is the arc shot you wanna get in
get it shot okay so my strategy is gonna
be to look at the cup okay ready I need
a little victory dance so cuz I made it
so here's my victory all you have to do
just think of wanting to throw this at
your head and have it drop right in her
so pumped right now next the two pointer
bounce shot bounce shot is a little
trickier because Kinzie could swat it
away
oh I can yeah you can swat away this is
fun but if it's in the air you can't
swap I have to swat it after the bounce
after the bounce yeah but if I bounce it
then you can swallow okay what if I
throw it then you can okay if your team
sinks both shots balls back ball back in
the case of a ball that bounces back
without hitting the floor
the player can attempt a trick shot I am
now gonna try to make my game harder I'm
gonna do a trick shot which means I'm
gonna go behind my back even though the
table is really high for a short person
so I making it doubly hard because
technically I think the table should be
lower just gonna say that okay ready
here I go
that was a whole trick shot behind the
back and I want you to just take a
breath okay
oh and try it again try it again don't
be hard on yourself you got this all
right yep
also close ah one more as you start to
sink some shots and your cups get
further and further apart restock what's
that mean no or per official terminology
the rear AK a rewrap oh you said it
wrong doesn't count
doesn't count each team gets one
reracked per game Brian and Angela opted
for a honeycomb restock tickle Brian
okay here we go you got it you got it no
you don't you got it now that Brian and
Angela have covered shooting it's time
to discuss defensive strategies
[Music]
distraction I don't need to distract her
look now they'll put it all together no
oh good good so now this is removed yeah
I drink this oh my god this is so much
fun but you know be responsible oh one
more drink
Oh nope nope stop mocking me in that way
[Music]